we know that the narratives that are
formed in the lead-up to criminal cases
obviously have an impact on both juries
and how prosecutions conduct their case
we saw this in the derek chauvin trial
where without any evidence whatsoever
that case was made the face the bleeding
edge of racism in the united states
there was no evidence that chovan was
racist it was not even alleged in the
courtroom the media instead decided it
was a referendum on all cops and a
referendum on racism in the united
states with written house they did the
same thing they said this is a
referendum somehow on racism
okay now they're having a tough time
with this one because rittenhouse number
one is not a white supremacist and
number two the people he shot were all
white
all three had criminal records one of
them was a child child molester
so
this was not the the best case to pick
if you're a member of the media and you
wish to talk about the evils of domestic
terror white supremacists running around
but the goal you have to remember when
this happened with written house was to
posit that there was a great conflict in
the nation between the morally just blm
rioters and trump supporters who are
evil that was the conflict they were
trying to create this case didn't fit
inside that conflict at all the conflict
itself was stupid it didn't make any
sense but the media had a narrative and
whatever the narrative had to be they
were going to cram this into it well
this is where you would expect the
system of justice to actually do its job
and stand aside they didn't the system
of justice decided
that that it was necessary to bring a
criminal case against kyle written house
because of the public pressure and at
the time again i was willing to withhold
judgment until i saw all the evidence
now we've seen all the evidence let me
just tell you this prosecutor ought to
be disbarred there's no way this case
should have been brought it's insane
that this case was brought based on the
evidence so kyle rittenhouse yesterday
takes the stand now as a lawyer i got to
tell you first year criminal law they
tell you if you got a client do not let
your client take the stand because
especially uh like unless the evidence
really runs against you and you feel
that it is definitely necessary that you
need your clients to take the stand you
don't put your client on the stand
because you just don't know what's gonna
happen courtrooms are unpredictable
juries aren't predictable you don't know
how they're gonna react to particular
testimony
okay but ridden house decided to take
the stand
and again that's kind of an incredible
thing you got to remember it's an
incredible thing because the prosecutor
had completely failed to make his case
in the days leading up to this i mean i
did a lot on the podcast monday about
this in the days leading up to yesterday
written houses prosecutors did a
horrible job they were calling witness
after witness
the prosecution and those witnesses were
quickly turning into defense witnesses
gage gross glutes or whatever the guy's
name is he he was the guy who was shot
in the arm by rittenhouse
he was asked by the prosecutor if he was
if he was if he had dropped his gun or
or what was going on and instead he was
like oh yeah yeah and i was pointing my
gun at him i mean he literally just made
the defense case for the defense it was
incredible
and that sort of testimony was very
common the prosecutor would call a
witness the witness would testify to
written house's innocence and then the
prosecutor would kind of throw up his
hand
so finally written house takes the stand
yesterday
and it didn't go great for the
prosecution
okay so let's begin with clip 29 okay so
the prosecutor asks him about one of the
people that he shot i named him huber
okay and and this is the guy who if you
recall the footage
just to go through the timeline here
written house was running away from a
fire there was a big fire and ringhouse
was running away from the fire and a and
a man
confronted him and started yelling at
him apparently he had confronted him
earlier in the night
this would be joseph rosenbaum and
started chasing him
rittenhouse ran away even though i did a
gun right he'd been there to kill him
just shot him there he wasn't he ran
away
rosenbaum chased him down
and rittenhouse turned around rosenbaum
grabbed for his gun and written house
shot him
ridden house then stood there
as a reporter came over a reporter from
the daily caller came over and uh and
tried to provide medical aid to
rosenbaum who was bleeding out and a
crowd started together and ringhouse
didn't feel safe so he started trying to
run toward the cops
as he was running toward the cops
he was pursued by a bunch of antifa
thugs
one of those antifa thugs was hoover who
jumped on him with a skateboard and
started trying to clock him in the head
with the skateboard
okay because he was now prone he'd
fallen down and tripped and fallen
and rittenhouse shot
huber and then
gage grosskroot decided that he was
going to get in on the action and he ran
over with his pistol
pointed at written house and how shot
him in the arm
okay that is the timeline here
so actually let's start with uh with
clip two so rittenhouse
it was asked by the prosecutor why he
was running and he says because there
was a fire
you decided you needed to run because of
the fire on the duramax yes why what was
so urgent
it was a fire
there's fires all over the place
so i was getting to the fire to put it
out
we'll get back to that in a second
okay so
great job here great job
um good job prosecutor why were you
running to a fire well there were fires
everywhere why why are you running that
fire
uh excuse me
i have a question is that also how you
like
well if a firefighter gets a phone call
and he says go to a fire
would you say to him there are many
other fires in the city sir why aren't
you going to those as well like that
what are you even talking about
what are you talking about
okay
then
the prosecutor asks you know why did you
shoot this anthony huber character this
26 year old who is swinging a skateboard
at him
and um
rittenhouse gives the obvious answer
because he was trying to hit me in the
head with his skateboard which could
kill me
and when you
shoot him
he's got his skateboard in his hand
yes
you didn't see
any gun in his hand correct
you didn't see a knife no you didn't see
a bat no you didn't see a club no all
he's got is the skateboard right that
he's hit me in the head with twice yes
okay
and he's hitting me in the head with
twice
okay as it turns out under american law
i don't have to wait for you to hit me
in the head with a skateboard the third
time
once you've hit me in the head with the
skateboard the first time i can by the
way if you come at me with a skateboard
and you swing back and you are about to
hit me in the head i can shoot you
before you hit me
self-defense is still a part of american
law and by the way all
western common law and by the way all
non-western law
okay like i'm unaware of any state
anywhere where self-defense is not a
thing where if somebody swings they
skateboard at your head you're supposed
to just stand there and take it
okay and then the prosecutor suggests
the written house is just out to shoot
people
and rent house like uh i didn't want to
shoot people i mean you can see in the
tape that he's holding back from
shooting people
you just assumed
that he was going to use it
that he was going to try and take it
from you first of all and then you
assumed he was going to try and use it
on you
if i would have let mr roosevelt get my
gun he would have killed me
but you had already pointed your gun at
him
yes because he was chasing me did you
want him to think that you were gonna
shoot him no i never wanted to shoot mr
rosenbaum
why'd you point it at him if you didn't
have any intention of shooting
he was chasing me i was alone he
threatened to kill me earlier in that
night
i didn't want to have to shoot him
okay i love how the prosecutors suggest
that if you point a gun in the vicinity
of a person who is chasing you with
violent intent to threaten to kill you
that this me and then you don't shoot
this means you meant to shoot
okay and then written house is asked
about the the third character who
attacked him gage gross groots
and um and he says to him you know you
had a rifle he had a pistol so what made
you think you had to shoot him i don't
understand does this prosecutor not
understand how guns operate
like what what
this is not a video game
a pistol can kill you just as easily as
a rifle can particularly when you're
about eight feet apart as they are in
the video
they are on top of one another
this is not kyle rittenhouse out at
sniper distance engaged gross crews
walking around the perimeter carrying a
pistol
this is gage grosskroot pulling a gun
out raising it up about ten feet away
from kyle rittenhouse who's prone on his
back here's the prosecutor this
prosecutor's a mockery he's just a
mockery
he's got a pistol not aimed at you
you've got an ar-15 aimed at him
why is he more of a threat to you
than you are to him
because he wasn't he was moving at me
with a gun in his hand
this is right after you've killed
anthony huber correct yes right after
you fire two shots at almost point-blank
range at the man running towards the
camera right now and missing him correct
yes
and you're telling us
gage gross croits is the real threat at
this moment
yes
i mean yeah
have you seen the video like i don't
know how
ass backwards you have to be not to be
able to to watch that video and come
away with the idea that great gage gross
which is not a lethal threat if a man a
pro if you fall on the on your back
you're running away from people
you fall on your back you got your rifle
here somebody approaches you with his
pistol he's withdrawing it
to shoot you
and the prosecutor is like why would you
feel like you were in dire threat you
mean he wasn't coming to give you like a
christmas present he wasn't coming over
they'd give you a nice shot how do you
know maybe he was gonna drop the pistol
and come over there and give you a bear
hug
maybe he's gonna give you a foot massage
like what in the world what in the
actual so written house is asked why
were you trying to get to the cops after
the first shooting why are you trying to
get to the cops and he says because i
was defending myself like what do you
not understand about the english
language sir
people were saying cranium him and get
him
kill him
people were screaming and i just was
trying to get to the police running down
sheridan road and you say i'm trying to
get to the police why were you trying to
get to the police so i didn't do
anything wrong i defended myself
okay so this testimony goes very very
poorly for the prosecution like super
poorly for the prosecution but the left
has to have its narrative because
remember they've doubled down on the
notion that rittenhouse's white
supremacist murderer who went out that
night to shoot people the evidence is
precisely the opposite it does not
matter they have to have their victim
they have to have their their blood here
and written house has to go down so they
need something to hang their hat on and
what they decide to hang their hat on is
the fact that written house cried
yesterday at the trial
that is what they've hung their hat on
okay so
yesterday written is is getting beat up
by the prosecutor he's being asked over
and over about shooting people he's 18
years old so he's a young man now the
reason i use the term young man here is
because i want to be consistent right
michael brown was also a young man when
he attacked a police officer and when he
was shot for his trouble okay so when
you're 17 years old 18 years old i'm i'm
hesitant in a criminal justice context
to use different terminology for
different people based on based on the
age right if you're 17 18 years old you
are now a young man so
written house in this in if you were if
you were a kid then
not only should he not have been out on
the street there had been no excuse for
him to be out on the street if he's 14
years old 13 years old but he's 17 years
old he's out there he's a young man okay
so
that does not mean that it's not rather
an emotional thing when you're on trial
for your life for having shot three
career criminals essentially
okay so so written house is being beat
up by the prosecutor and he starts
crying
and it was
pretty intense testimony right he
essentially has a panic attack
that's basically what happens on the
stand
and frankly i can't really blame him
i mean if you were called to testify for
your life in a trial that was so
ridiculous on its face
and and you knew that you'd had to shoot
three people
you hadn't wanted to shoot going out
there you brought the gun to defend
yourself and you had to defend yourself
that's not an easy thing and now you're
on trial for your life with a prosecutor
who's attacking you for shooting people
attempting to hit you in the head with a
skateboard and approaching you to grab
your gun and alternatively trying to
point a pistol at you
you might have a panic attack on stan
too and that's essentially what happened
with with written house yesterday here's
what that sounded like
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
people right there
that's right
[Applause]
okay so
the media's response to this in large
part is he's lying this shows he's a
fake there are people who are tweeting
out photos of him next to of course
brett kavanaugh because
all white people who cry are apparently
the same and not only that also brett
kavanaugh we know was lying because he
got upset too it turns out that when
you're up when you are accused of a
thing you did not do you tend to get
upset but apparently according to the
media
your your tears are some sign of guilt
so you have for example
lebron james who tweeted out
lebron is just i'm sorry lebron is just
kind of a garbage human i mean he's just
a bad person he's just a bad person
a person who spends all day whining
about how america is deeply racist while
he becomes one of the wealthiest people
in the country
who bullies people into saying nothing
about chinese human rights violations
but he has time to suggest that kyle
rittenhouse is um
is lying and this is all false here's
what lebron james tweeted quote what
tiers five question marks
i didn't see one
man knock it off that boy ate some lemon
heads before walking into court
and then three emojis of laughing crying
yeah i mean
coming from a guy who uh who acts like a
soccer player on the court frequently
i i will not take acting lessons from
lebron james
and uh and i've noticed that um
[Music]
again lebron lebron has a lot to say
when it comes to defending the chinese
government and
pretty much nothing to say when it comes
to the question of due process for
people he doesn't particularly like
what what a god send lebron james is
he has every right to speak his mind and
frankly i'm glad he does because he
demonstrates what kind of person he is
pretty much every time he goes on
twitter
you'll recall this is not the last time
this is not the first time lebron james
had to do this
you remember that that just back in
april he had to delete a tweet about a
police shooting of makia bryant in
columbus ohio
right you'll remember that mckia bryant
was a 16 year old black girl who was
attacking another black girl with a
knife and a cop drove up and had to
shoot her
and lebron james tweeted out
in giant letters your next all caps your
next hashtag accountability and an
hourglass emoji
and then added i'm so damn tired of
seeing black people killed by police i
took the tweet down because it's being
used to create more hate it's about the
entire system they always use our words
to create more racism i'm so desperate
for more accountability
yeah sure lebron what what a delight he
is we need more we we need more of
lebron's insightful political commentary
to make the world a better place really
in space jam 3 i look forward to him
maligning an innocent person i mean
mine's an innocent cop for saving a
black person and now he's maligning kyle
rittenhouse is a guy who eats lemonheads
before going into court while he's on
trial for his life
space jam 3 should just be about in an
innocent person being victimized and
lebron james standing on them and
spitting
that's what space jam 3 should be about
what a genius he is
meanwhile miriam webster got into the
act you want your local dictionary to
get into the act on these things it's
very very important so merriam-webster
tweeted out
the term crocodile tears a superficial
display of anguish comes from a medieval
belief that crocodiles shed tears of
sadness when killing their prey
they tweeted that out in the middle of
the trial
because merriam-webster is now run their
twitter account at least is run by
wokesters so people who literally are
defining the words you use in english
are
sounding off this way in the middle of a
trial
hakeem jefferies
a progressive congressman from new york
he gets in on the act he tweets out lock
up kyle rittenhouse and throw away the
key
based on what exactly based on what
anna navarro
you're a supposed in-house republican in
places like cnn in the view
she tweets how kyle written house shot
and killed anthony huber 26 and joseph
rosenbaum 36 and injured gage gross
groots now 27 think about how much their
loved ones have cried real anguish and
grief not crocodile tears
hey by the way um you can see in this
picture the actual tears on his face so
uh when so lebron is not only stupid
he's blind apparently
but uh anna navarro here saying that um
you have to think about the families of
joseph rosenbaum who was a child
molester a serial child molester and
gage grosskroots who was attacking a 17
year old who's burnt on the ground with
a pistol and anthony huber
who had a criminal record and was
swinging a swinging a skateboard at this
guy's head think about how much their
loved ones have cried real anguishing
with not crocodile tears see he cried
that was a big problem as he cried
benjamin dixon another blue check on
twitter tweeted out similarly proud boys
is trending not looking so proud now are
you boy
the language here is really quite a
delight quite a delight ryan grimm from
the intercept joins he says what people
could do with anger about the written
house trial is advocate for a law that
says that if you bring a weapon to a
public place where you know violence is
basically guaranteed you lose any
self-defense grounds
uh that makes
that makes a lot of sense so basically
if you bring a weapon to defend yourself
to any unsafe area in the united states
and someone attacks you you can now be
murdered at whim
great job everyone that makes perfect
sense great job everyone
okay so you can see
with this sort of climate
that's the reason the prosecutor brought
this thing
this thing because there's no other
reason for him to have brought this case
he's got nothing he's got less than
nothing he made himself look like a fool
this trial is a joke it's been a joke
beginning to i kept waiting honest to
god i kept waiting for them to bring
forth the piece of evidence that we
hadn't seen already and then every
additional piece of evidence was worse
for the prosecution
as somebody who generally wants to
uphold institutional trust
as somebody who believes the criminal
justice system
is imperfect but generally does a decent
job it is hard to watch trials like this
and believe that sort of thing
i'm going to chalk this one up to a bad
apple in the prosecutor but it seems
more and more often that criminal
justice trials are now being brought
simply because of public pressure
brought by the media the media can whip
up an outrage and then you just use the
prosecutor as the as the
head of the mob in order to go after
somebody it's really disgusting
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content